but let's talk about this article it's
interesting there's a guy that move it's
from a business insider
that's the rag that just ran that hit
piece on davey portnoy
and they were gonna run a hit piece on
me
and one comic this kid who was an open
mic comedian who quit
then went to work for business insider
interviewed me i was down in florida he
called me i spoke to him for an hour you
know
you know the question you know alex
jones and you
did a podcast together
what was that about
what was it like
why are you you say some things that
anger people
why do you do it
what is it about
and i sat there in a parking lot smoking
cigarettes suffering through this
interview because nobody asks any good
questions
where are you from
were you always a contrarian
did you know alex jones when you were a
baby
they're the worst questions ever because
journalists are stupid they're not and
they're not journalists
journalists are people who have white
hair and [ __ ] in libraries you look at
microfiche and they try to solve the
kennedy assassination shannon knows
we've had him on the show they have no
money no one buys their books no one
cares and they die alone and unfulfilled
those are journalists or they go to like
a war-torn country they run around that
country people shoot at them they get
some guy to give them some story at a
cafe they win a pulitzer prize a year
later no one cares they get diagnosed
with cancer because they were too close
to like live ammunitions and they die
alone and unfulfilled this is what
journalists are and then you have
stenographers meaning that they just
write down things the government wants
them to say those people have big houses
they're on tv a lot they write books
that are always put out there they're in
the front of the bookstore and it's like
uh it's just a picture of uh you know
god only knows you know winston
churchill or fdr and they're like they
wrote a history of him which someone
else wrote they just kind of grabbed it
it's ghost written they said the
greatest generation you know tom broke
or any of those guys and their books are
pushed because they don't make any
trouble they don't cause any problems
and they're you know and they lie you
know like brian williams the guy who
just made things up and he lies and they
all lie because no one catches them and
lying is like a drug you get intoxicated
with doing it if nobody catches you and
that's so
those are the
class of journalists and then you have
these like new york
media types who like write for these
glorified blogs and they don't have any
money and they eat ramen and they live
on the floor
and they have a degree from like
syracuse university or some other
embarrassing school
oh the new school of journalism is good
who cares uh or colombia which is an ivy
or whatever and they're these people are
so mad that they don't have talent
they're so and so they love other people
that don't have talent so they love
unfunny comedians they love it and they
write stories like who's the next [ __ ]
because they have no talent they go
where can i go to find people that like
me
are incredibly deficient in any
noticeable skill
and they find them and they go these are
25 comedians that you're gonna know
and they get in this little group of
people
and no one cares and they don't have any
money and they get angry at people like
dave portnoy uh because he he's again
has a media operation and he's taking
eyeballs away from people like cnn from
espn and bigger um uh platforms that are
losing eyeballs to barstow sports in the
same way that our patreons like the
number two in america there are people
that lose uh eyeballs and ears or
whatever to us because they enjoy this
show so the new york media types and
it's not oh and i don't mean jews and i
don't so don't tweet at me
and and because there's a lot of
christians doing this too shamefully
and probably a few scientol i'm kidding
the scientologists are they've they
figured it out
but the new york media because new york
is the media capital of the world these
people are always they always have it
out for people like rogan and because
these guys are threat independent
operations are threats they're big
threats that's why i don't run away from
the media you can call me media all day
i don't really care
um i think it's uh funny media if i am
media you just also have to be media
sitting at a desk with a suit on working
for
nbc and the saudi royal family you also
have to be considered me if i'm media
your media we're all media baby
so this comic calls me what's it like to
be yeah
and then i answer all the questions then
i forget about it completely because i
don't care about it and business
insiders is uh you know as a rag but
we're going to talk about their
anti-work article but a lot of people
have this article the guardian whatever
this is the one
that caught my eye it's a rag and they
write inflammatory stuff like this
article it's kind of like no one's
there's a movement because this is meant
to piss off people that are working they
write an article like this you're like
nobody's working anymore you are sucker
and and dave portnoy's gonna spit in
your daughter's mouth tomorrow dave
portnoy's choking your daughter today
how does that make you feel you got a
wife well dave portnoy's choking her
he's choking women in damn talking he's
running around nantucket grabbing every
woman he sees at the farmer's market and
spitting down the throat i'm true
doesn't seem to be what's happening okay
i did go to barcelo sports and he spit
my mouth it was a bit i think it was a
joke i don't know he spit my mouth and
said pig and then walked away it was
jarring but not entirely unexpected and
it was somewhat enjoyable
he
uh
has kind of proven they were after him
this comic calls me
uh the day
the portnoy stuff breaks and he goes hey
i quit insider because they wouldn't run
a hit piece on you i don't know if
you've wondered why the piece has never
come out and i said i haven't wondered
that because i don't care i don't really
know who you are and i was like the
eating sushi parked in a handicapped
spot outside of bristol farms and i was
more concerned with that and he goes
well it didn't come out because they
they wanted me to run a hit piece on you
and i said on me
they want to run a hit piece on me
and yes they wanted to run a hit piece
on me and say i was some reactionary
right right-wing lunatic nut job you
know the way these people operate
so
i'm
not too shocked by what happened to dave
and what will happen to anyone
if you have an opinion that runs
counter